all right we are
live with Arin nonduality
yeahia
Chia ER the Sun is
bright yeah it is yeah that's so cool
that your name also means
that yeah yeah yeah yeah somehow yeah in
the story when er was born mom didn't
know what name to put and um neighbor
who was also um children's doctors came
and watched the baby this one and said
oh she looks so energetic and blah blah
blah put and that I means bright yeah
it's not very popular name in Estonia
right yeah the less popular the cooler
in in ways yeah and I and I love this I
love the single the single name I
remember I don't remember if it's called
like a mononym or something it's like
when someone goes by one name it's fun
like and it's a powerful name like er
you know that's
cool yeah in the story it meant
something you know right bright
yeah super
meing yeah yeah to to be to be that the
to to wear that name yeah it it was uh
yeah it was little bit like special and
and special for me also right right have
a special name yeah and uh and somehow
in the story couple of years here it
have been problems to pronounce or to
say the name when somebody is asking
what what is your name then it's like
who what yes yes yes and it doesn't have
like any meaning or some something like
that this H this label didn't fit here
and I didn't understand what's going on
and uh of course now it doesn't matter
at at all call me as like and that's
that's the weird thing that's why we are
so uh programmed and obsessed with names
because we just how how would we refer
to the
bodies if there weren't cuz there's
obviously
namelessness and unity but how but how
would you how would you refer to
apparent bodies if without the name so
that's why we're so conditioned to ask
you know what's the name so I know how
to refer to that specific body when I
want it to can you grab me a cup of tea
or whatever yeah you
know yeah it's very practical yeah yeah
EX exactly it's just simple practical
yeah yeah
yeah just make a sound a random sound
which is a name and then that refers to
that body yeah yeah yeah and and it's
difficult here because the name is
sounds like hello in the stone it's Tera
so whenever I am in a street or or a
shop or people are saying D to others
and I'm like oh what they're saying
hello to each other but I I I hear that
they say my name this part reacts to
that name still
yeah yeah and by the way your your
background is not a wallpaper cuz I'm
sure that some people would might think
wow it's such a beautiful background
yeah it's not a wallpaper it's literally
the Spanish Coast the gorgeous Spanish
Coast yeah oh it's so cool yeah so
blessed yeah I'm so so in love in in in
Spain and somehow first time when came
here I don't know when it was long time
ago uh it felt like a home and in the
story here was the story that in in
Prior life or previous life there I was
Spanish right now the stories are no
more but uh but yeah right right because
it so so so good here in
Spain
cool
wow yeah it's um the fascinating thing
about the subject and you know I have
your I have your uh your website up
right now and I I'm a big I'm a big fan
of of what you wrote on your website
just in the sense of how short it is
because there's really so nothing to say
about it and I think there's just a
really concise way that you said things
on your site and and I think your blogs
are are also really on point like that
specific area where you write about it
is is really beautiful and you also do a
really fun job on on YouTube also so I
got I got that up fun content up there
go and check the channel out subscribe
to the to whatever blah blah is coming
out of these
mouths um yeah so I love I just I love
the Simplicity I love the Simplicity
because we can't say anything about it
and yet every word is it so how do so
how do you how do you what are you what
are you doing like you got you got
people that come and they're like oh my
God I don't get it and you're like
there's nothing to get you're already it
there's no you
exactly yeah game over game
over yeah but but apparently in in the
conversation there um different
questions can can arise and uh and yeah
and you can't do nothing even when it's
heard that you can't understand this but
still it functions this way that it
tries to understand or to ask the
questions to exhaust the Seeker or this
energy right because there are no
answers it's like running with your head
to the wall continuously continuously
yeah yeah yeah until it's a yeah nothing
to get yes the one who is uh who who
wants to get something or tries to
understand it somehow evaporates or or
yeah right yeah yeah but but you you
will never get this no one will get this
at least I didn't get anything yes yes
yes yes yes exactly I love I love that
uh the head the head against the wall B
and that's kind of what it was like like
going under flipping over every single
Rock opening up every single book
traveling to every single country
sitting with every single Guru taking
psychedelic sitting meditate whatever
it's all just like B hit head against
wall repeatedly until apparently some
sort of contracted
energy just stops
yeah
yeah explod to the Boneless this is
another story of course nothing doesn't
explode because there isn't anything to
explode the explosion is the only thing
that is
yeah yeah yeah in instant constant
explosion yes yes big bang
pingang yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah oh my gosh and and that's it's
fascinating cuz isn't it's almost like
the explosion itself is enough it's
already fulfilled it's
already miraculous and ordinary and
magical and then and then there's
something that overlooks that and then
says that no that's not it yeah yeah
yeah there's more that I can get somehow
yeah
yeah and that's funny because uh no no's
doing it even you know no one's seeking
no one's turning the rocks or taking the
psychedelics or meditating or this and
that and then there is a story that I
need like 50 years of seeking yeah there
is no 50 years yes yes yes yes yes and
there is no one doing the seeking or
starting the seeking or ending the
seeking also yes Alpha and Omega you end
where you started and nothing
happened yeah somehow you have to do in
the story
The arrive back there and yeah yeah it's
it's kind of like it's almost like a
when you get a when you get something
like whether it's like a like a romantic
relationship or a um like a home or a
car or whatever you get you get
something and then the first thing that
comes up is no no no that's not enough I
need more than that and yeah and like
that's endlessly yeah yeah
yeah it's enough for 3 minutes or so
yeah yeah three minutes what's next yeah
yeah exactly Never Enough yeah
gosh crazy how this uh this plays out
that this uh apparent separation or
whale fails this to see this that there
is nothing
else and uh this but this apparent
separation can feel so yeah lonely or or
something is constantly missing because
I'm not enough I'm not full I need to do
something or arrive somewhere or know
more or get more yes yes nice to feel
this this end endless hole Yeah and then
at the end you are in a death bed two
seconds before smiling ah it's enough
yeah always enough yes yes
yes yeah release always happens when the
body passes and it seems to it seems to
and then the this I like how you
describe it cuz I describe it so
similarly that it's like that un that
unfulfilled that lack and then it's
always instead of being the open
spaciousness that it is it's like trying
to fill the void trying to fill it with
endless X object y object Z object that
will do it that will do it that will do
it nope nothing ever does it so just
being
that the beauty
of just the simple ordinary nonpar is
just it's just it's so easily overlooked
yeah yeah yeah by
nothing yeah yeah but this is enough
this is more than enough and isn't it
isn't it isn't do do you do you I mean
it's just the story but do you do you
attribute at least a little bit when you
talk about this do you attribute it at
least a little bit to the conditioning
of like parents Society culture that
you're not enough until you achieve this
thing or you get this thing then you'll
be worthy do you do you say that
sometimes that that's what yeah I say
that uh this is just a conditioned body
and uh sometimes when the this illusion
gets thinner and thinner and thinner so
to speak uh although there is no process
but in in that process it feels like
it's process and I am dying and oh I'm
losing all the meaning and uh falling
apart or however it appears to different
bodies but still the conditionings
running like the car run out of the fuel
but car is still moving or wheels are
still spinning these are the
conditionings but then the story came
that oh I still get agitated or I still
get frustrated it means like my me is
still back or still here or something
all these nonsense
stories and uh and yeah I'm just
expressing that um these are just
conditionings programming this is like
the
computer uh self i i e a i i right
something like that right right yeah
yeah yeah you don't do anything I love
that you don't learn you yeah you can do
nothing yeah and your parents didn't do
nothing also I love that yes it's just
what's happening apparently right right
right there is no one's fault yes no one
to blame yes yes oh that's so and no
credits right yeah right no credits yeah
yeah exactly no blame no credits yeah
yeah I love that
yeah that's
great right yeah it is like the the AI
program running of of selfing or lacking
and needing and more and more and Ming
and there's no one to blame for it it's
all that autonomous flow of light and
and there's and that and there's that
freedom in a way of not um victimizing
by blaming parent or Society or culture
and then there's well and not crediting
too it's not crediting any sort of uh uh
xob that caused the dissolution of the
selfing yeah yeah yeah because then
everyone in New Age culture goes to that
object if that's said as soon as you say
it was xob that caused the dissolution
New Age culture makes it a new course or
a new program or
whatever yeah probably yeah this is also
innocent happening also innocent yeah
yeah exactly yeah like everything is
perfect and uh the person the individual
doesn't understand this because there is
always something wrong there is war
there is um death there is raping
whatever how you say that this is
perfect but some freaky way even when
here is lots of pain or uh problems with
the I don't know money or or health
whatever it's also perfect it's also
perfect everything is perfect everything
is innocently perfect nothing wrong with
with anything this this is full yes
there is nothing else nice to make this
more full yes yes nice nice it is full
the the natural Harmony or frequency of
the light is fullness yeah yeah and I
like what I like what you were just
saying there it's um there was like like
three three or so years ago I was
playing football with friends and I slid
in the rain while catching a ball and
hit the side of my body against a metal
steak that was kind of hidden buried in
the ground and it snapped a bunch of my
ribs and penetrated my lungs and
deflated the lung and it was fascinating
cuz there was that like immediately
there was like kind of like in a way it
felt like dying and then it also felt
like right away there was no one to
blame there was only the wisdom of the
of of what was of what was happening and
like like seeing that as right away
there was no there was no um like V
victimization there was only right away
like like the beauty even of such pain
is is some is just it's just what is and
what is happening and it's the
Perfection of your lung being deflated
and your ribs being broken the
Perfection of that and it's like how do
you say that that's and there was in the
car ride to the hospital where it was
just so much of that pain and there was
like you know people looking and like
being like why is that body not freaking
out why is it saying that this is
perfect that doesn't make any sense yeah
yeah and like that's what you would say
like how could War be perfect like you
were saying
yeah yeah yeah some freaky way it is
only Perfection and here also when I was
in I think Thailand I was uh falling and
had injury and uh while I was falling
the body had still memory because it uh
fell um on the snow couple of months
before like it was slippery and the head
went back and there was like concussion
happening and uh wanting to sleep after
that and uh and uh yeah the foggy seeing
and uh and so when when was the second
time it was like in in the millisecond
or how how fast it is I don't know the
whole life and not again yeah and I
don't know how it hints it was like but
uh yeah then then I was coming to my um
husband right and I was like bleeding
everything was okay I don't know also
going to the ambulance then sitting like
one week in the room couldn't go outside
to to too hot because open wounds that I
had to uh to every day to change the the
bandaging yeah bandages yeah yeah yeah I
had in back and hand and leg
geez yeah and you felt the perfection
even of
that yeah and no story that oh [__] the
vacation is ruined right because in that
the same same vacation we went to the
spontaneously to the
Vietnam uh because somebody was uh
inviting us now very good friend and uh
also from non so we have lots lots of to
talk about about this nothing and there
was diarrhea or stomach bug happening
and again one week in the room but yeah
the the easy part is that there is no
blaming or or guilt or why I ate that or
I should be more cu careful when going
down the stairs to the to the Sea
and right right or or or when when this
body is eating something really I don't
know crap like real crap and feeling bad
after the stomach feeling bad the body
feels not good but no stories exactly in
a story years ago when when here was
this Fitness lifestyle happening all the
blaming all the guilt okay tomorrow I go
for running or I eat only I don't know
clean and
punishing why I did this why I did that
it's just what's happening apparently no
one's doing it and this body wants to
feel good so it doesn't uh maybe
sometimes there is idea you eat some
cake or or or chips or something and
then thinking and already my stomach
starts to hurt because this is what may
happen and then it's okay I don't want
right but but if eating happens and
getting pains after um it's
Perfection yeah damn that kind of the
looping of the of the of the uh arguing
basically with what is it's like looping
in argument with what is because as and
then that's the thing that can like
quote ruin a vacation or whatever
apparently is that that thing like the
whole thing becomes like a victim story
or like arguing with what what is and
yeah
yeah even the story when when when I had
this stomach bug in Vietnam and the
doctor um gave me antibiotics that I
didn't take because this body doesn't
seem to like medicine this this kind of
medicine and on the fifth day when I
hadn't eaten five days slept normally
couldn't go out because I had to stay
close to the toilet and I also was doing
meetings uh nity meetings there without
any sleep and then finally something
take the bill and then it took couple of
hours maybe and it was
gone buty felt normal and then the
thought came that why I didn't listen
and why I I didn't take the first day
and then it was like laughing because
there is no
choice this is perfection to for uh five
days in the bin yeah yes yes yes yeah
exactly no choice exactly and then it's
gone
yeah yeah yeah yeah almost one of the
ways that it could be described with the
story is to say that like it's Catalyst
in a way like C like Catalyst for um for
what is to sort of
um is itself I I don't I don't know how
to say it's like just the the the isness
uses catalysts in a way to to make a
parent change happen and it's because
then then you could we share a story
which is we're when when these injuries
happened there wasn't a a a addiction to
a victim story and then we share that on
this conversation and then uh Apparently
that is heard by nothing and it's like
okay uh perhaps that victim story won't
Loop next time and so yeah it's so
so so so interesting yeah but you never
know this is unconditional freedom and
every story is free to Loop
also yeah but it doesn't seem to happen
uh here at least anymore and but it's
it's total freedom so everything can
happen and no one knows what's going to
happen you may plan your full vacation
or full year but actually you don't have
[__] clue what's going to happen next
second that may change all your plans so
to speak you know yes yes how how to how
to make God love don't your plans yeah
do your
C yes there's a there is no separate God
disclaimer there's no separate cut yes
yes yeah
the the Indescribable love and freedom
and Perfection of this just without any
control or manipulation or um or lack of
to change it and yet also the body
continues functioning it continues um
you know building whatever it's building
this body is building whatever this the
show the the basic needs infrastructures
that it's working on and it's it's
excited about that it's excited about
like children being born without the
need to go and sell their time for money
to pay for basic needs and that's and
what happens then you wake up and you
play you know wake up and play um yeah
so the body functionality goes on yeah
yeah nothing changes when when the me
apparently collapses because they're
never was a me so what change nothing
but yeah at the same time everything is
different somehow when these classes are
off
yeah yeah there's a there's some uh
there's comment in how um it's like in
in the chat about
how uh even non Duality is not a ground
which is yes of course so you know there
is there there is no lending yeah there
is no truth there is no you know final
realization yeah if there is the only
realization is that the one who could
realize is no more and haven't never
been so uh the enlightenment isn't
personal no one's get enlightened and I
don't know that of course I don't know
that these are just empty words coming
from nothing no one knows what's
speaking so to speak yeah this is
unknowable yeah
yeah yeah but but the in the story it
feels like
closest to the truth this so-called
radical
nality but of course there is no truth
yeah right right and it's it's
fascinating because even when one quote
pop pops out or whatnot that even then
it's still seen in a way by nothing that
the the point in a way is to still be in
the character in the on the stage of
what's appearing and so there's nowhere
to go you there's only the there's only
the Character Show Goes On The Show Goes
On yeah go there's no there's there's no
there's no difference between there
being no me and being me or there's and
then there can be a parent difference
and it just doesn't matter which which
one and but it can really matter if it's
really contracted it can really matter
it can appear to really be important
yeah yeah
yeah which is beautiful separate one
yeah that's true is is perfect yeah
because then if if that and when that
cuz it it apparently happened where
there was that and then that release and
that release is like you know it's
beautiful but it's also ordinary and
it's also like nothing changes at the
same time and yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then you can sort of feel
in a way more of the the unconditional
love imp Perfection that was that was
said that was said earlier and yet at
the same time that's also not an excuse
for repressing anger or like ra like
that's also like allowed that's
everything's allowed yeah yeah yeah and
it seems like uh these kind of emotions
even can be even more intense when there
is no controller choose
yeah who is suppressing who have the
stories that I should be this way or
that way or maintain this story of you
know
yes as as our friends or family members
see us so to speak This falls apart and
this can be very wild this is
unpredictable like everything it's just
illusion that uh the control that I have
a control and I know where this is going
if I do that then this happens it's a
[__] it's just a dream story and of
course nothing wrong with this dream
this apparent dream because yeah this is
all apparent
anyway I love I love how you said that
like it can get Amplified because in a
way it the non repression amplification
of whatever the
character is is is actually in a way
more authentic it's more athentic yeah
yeah it's yeah it's and then you you can
sort of see it kind of it repels certain
like you're weirdly dancing like as
whatever your non- repressed character
is and then you you can see certain
people are just like oh my God uh no
thank you and it like repels and then
others are like dude that's what's up
let's dance together and so that's like
how you can sort of begin telling that
like authen I is kind of
like uh cuz spirituality can be its own
kind of straight jacket like another
straight jacket and so when there's like
a seeing through of also like the
Paradigm of spirituality by no one then
there's
another uh repression which was
spirituality to be unstraight jacketed
yeah yeah yeah it's like dream inside
the dream all these borders and rules
extra what's coming with that
spirituality
it's oh exhausting yeah yeah you have to
be that way eat that and uh and yeah I
wanted to say something else but I I
forgot go ahead if you have a take a
moment see if you can recall what we
were talking about
spirituality what you
said here is no memory yeah it's
like that doesn't matter probably the I
mean the boxes and the bounds all of
those box boxes and Bounds I mean like
we you know we still you know water
bottle you know it's still like useful
boxes and Bounds and whatnot but the
whole Paradigm of attachment to boxes
and Bounds and then conceptualizing
about those endlessly all of that is
seem to be just an ocean and then just
trying to like put yeah put borders
around around water in the ocean yeah
yeah yeah yeah somehow this
this me is like the prisonment also it
feels like
prisonment and then then it's Freedom MH
and uh free to
express um at least this body can't um
um not afford but force force force to
do something what this body doesn't like
and actually this have been always the
case in in ER story as ER was grown up
with um freestyle parenting so didn't
have much rules uh no real religion also
so it felt like pretty like the
bird I could
um I could say for the childhood yeah
but yeah when the knee dies so to speak
it seems like you are even more you yeah
yeah but there is no you but Au
authenticity there is no play playing
any any any games or for fun why not but
uh yeah just to maintain the story of of
someone yeah doesn't seem to
happen too exhausting geez
yeah oh man what a weird like um in this
in this open space like some sort of
like um like like like fabricated prison
and then like some sort of release of
something that's not even there and like
what a [__] weird thing yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you can't talk about this
you can't escape this it's a dream dream
yeah or such a weird weird thing yeah
it's it's it's a play without the
players and no one did the play No One
there's no director or
programmer
yeah although I don't know
that yeah what a what a
miracle even the simple and ordinary is
so wow and perfect it's just there's
nothing that's missing it's just already
what is longed for it's just yeah it's
it's
just
and it's so weird because one of the one
of the things that um the the that was
apparent in the releasing was like in a
way learning how to just sit in a way
with what is without trying to move and
get something else and then now there's
just way more comfort with just sitting
and being just in perfect love with what
is and like then from that more
fulfilled empty space it's way more
obvious that the functionality of the
body can just be what it authentically
is towards whatever basic needs Freedom
or whatever it's not about me trying to
get something to fulfill this sense of
lack cuz I can't sit and be nothing and
just appreciate the appearance for what
it
is my gosh
it's amazing it's a wow yeah and so
ordinary extraordinary ordinary and
ordinary at the same time yes nice yeah
right right this light nothing it it's
just infinite the light itself is
infinite the energy itself is
infinite and so there's the ordinary and
extraordinary at
once
yeah all at once no time no linear time
yeah yes it's happening here in this
nowhere else the thoughts about tomorrow
also here stories about yesterday or the
past also here we don't have There Is No
Escape from from from this so to speak
yeah
yeah yeah and this can be freeing it
sounds maybe awful for the apparent
me but uh yeah this is I love it
yeah yeah I mean I love like you know ER
is so interesting the name itself and
the the like U part part of what
apparently feels like with this with the
release is that the the no one is like
the sunlight that shines forever for no
reason in its beauty and
magnificence and that's why there's also
such a lovely you know with era the name
and also just there's been so much
worship of the sun itself and the the
obvious unification of life itself it's
just these all of this is just too
obvious and then overlooked by by you
know all these all this kind of bodily
contraction and and then all this
industrial complex kind of also uh comes
up and then there's all kinds of
perversities in the industrial complex
like yeah you yeah it's like confirming
the UN you're unho confirming the UN
wholeness and then being like take my
course or my offering or kiss my feet or
whatever [__] and then you'll be
if you're lucky but you need to upgrade
you need to upgrade to my premium
package first you know yeah yeah so
there's all those perverse incentives
that are in that industrial spiritual
industrial complex and but it but it's
also fascinating because a dog doesn't
know any of that a baby doesn't know any
of that even people that are just kind
of normally in like sports news weather
conversations um sometimes there's in a
way there's already kind of love and no
separation in a way and there's not
there's not even any thought about
spirituality or needing to do something
yeah yeah in the story here when when uh
yeah we were uh spiritual also in a
spiritual path like uh like I was
shorter time my husband was longer time
longer time Seeker in the story but um
when it this illusion of two collapsed
apparently we didn't have nothing to
talk with our spiritual friends anymore
because there was so much stories about
manifestation years and years they
manifested lots of money or or
relationships and still doesn't seem to
be
happening and uh and yeah and these old
friends before that spiritual period so
to speak school friends and that time uh
it's more easy uh to
talk exactly yeah yes yes it's
fascinating that uh so sort of like
apparently Post Release that it's
actually more repelling to be around the
spiritual industrial complex and it's
more freeing to be around nobody nor
mes uh that are quote called you know uh
uh Matrix slaves or whatever um it's in
a way it's more freeing and more fun to
go to a sports event and tailgate and
play games and be loud and Rowdy and
free than it is to sit on a meditation
cushion or or sit in a round circle and
talk about our psychedelic experiences
or our Awakenings or
whatever is f isn't that isn't that so
like how the whole thing flips it's like
what the [__] that's why you can't
that's why can't talk about it because
you can't Orient there's no position to
to take like that
wow
yeah fun times fun times yeah yeah and
and the and the whole time those friends
of like the of like more
normies the were calling out like era
Atlas Etc they were calling it out
because they were like that's not real
that's not authentic that's not really
you the whole [__] Holy Spirit ritual
uh character that's been constructed
that's not real and then boom it
obviously wasn't real
yeah yeah that's why it seems to be like
dream inside the dream and maybe even
inside the
dream then then there is layers of I
don't know Awakening and seeing
something true but still there is
someone someone who sees this some
someone who got something who get
special yeah it's it's it's still it's
still a dream yeah yeah yeah yeah
someone who got it and is special and
with a big gold gold star and lots of
attainments on the on the uniform and
then with a little like flower sitting
on a chair with a little flower in the
background and uh and and and uh with a
big big audience of of lots of of lots
of serious Seekers with important
questions imp imparting
knowledge yeah
yeah when when when I was doing first
time toel I was like I don't know why
I'm here because everyone came to heal
something and I was like what it was
just like uh experimenting or or wanting
to try to new things when when it
happened here but I think it was like
third round or something like that when
here started to come also okay you know
stories are coming listening other
stories what others are doing and it's
somehow
you finally right right
like inside some uh rabbit hole right
yeah isn't isn't that interesting that
um actually hearing the stories of the
spiritual industrial complex sort of uh
reels us into
conditioning in in in that rabbit hole
that kind of never ends of like bouncing
between those experiences yeah it's
almost like if you never hear about that
spiritual industrial complex and you
kind of just like Coast in a
normal just life itself as a nice just
niceness like just being nice because
you feel like everything is is uh is
just life like that is is its own
version of wholeness without a spiritual
industrial complex and without release
and all kinds of Awakening narratives
and all kinds of stuff
yeah I think of my friends that are like
that are like mailmen or they just like
work at a like a like an engineering
shop or whatever they just kind of build
stuff or whatever just like normal just
normal friends like little small
business owners or small business
employees or whatever it's just kind of
like nor noral like no jargon about
spirituality
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah in in a story I I I was
or here was this um anger or frustration
after or when the process of Falling
Away was happening when was seen this
all this spirituality and this business
how how they basically say in in every
video that you are not enough one way or
another so come come here and I teach
you this or that or uh doing some
practice or
um [__] I forgot what I was saying again
yeah that you are not enough and that
come here and I can teach you how to be
enough yeah yeah yeah by the way there's
a whole self go ahead go ahead there's a
whole self-help industry that was built
around that too yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and if it helps in a dream what's wrong
with that yeah have fun
but um trying to lose your ego or
yourself
whatever yeah then run away when there
is some method or practice given because
who is doing this it's still the me
doing this right right trying to um
dissolve or something it's still the me
and then the me is going to the
background or how to say it in in
English and uh and yeah but it's also
what's happening but what I was saying
was that here was anger towards to the
teachers to the spiritual teachers
because and I was following them little
bit and and thought that they are
enlightened because they have been in
India and done this meditation 20 years
didn't not do nothing and and and then
hearing that they they are selling that
but of course uh although here the the
the me started to see dissolve or the
sense of me
it felt like yeah this is dissolving or
here is no one but it still felt like
there is someone like there are teachers
who are doing this intentionally just
for money and maybe not all of them but
yeah when in Estonia is quite quite
small
so yeah and uh but of course that's also
innocent yeah I don't see the Seeker I
don't see the
teacher um it's the play of of this
Duality or this dream this illusion
what's happening and that's too is
innocent and um perfect yes there is no
guru there is no I don't know holy or
prophets or Gods I mean separate
yeah yeah oh my gosh this whole uh this
whole uh self-help industry has become
just
unbelievably like bloated um like that
yeah you you're you're uh not enough and
uh come and become enough become enough
yeah become enough basically that's the
it's like a kind of like a drum of
become enough become enough become
enough become enough become enough
become enough become enough you're not
enough become enough you're not enough
you're unho you're unworthy you're unho
you're unworthy come get it unworthy
yeah you're unworthy you're come get
what you see come get what you seek you
can find it you can find it through me
through my course through my course
through my book through my whatever you
know it's like this big book you don't
have what I have you don't have what I
have you don't have what I have yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
God yeah yeah gez huge and I don't have
nothing yeah the freedom of not having
anything yeah and the fullness of of
that the fullness of it yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah somehow so empty
and so full the fullness of this
Universal magic of the simple leaves in
the wind and the bird shps and the sun
set over the ocean and all kinds of
[__] magic these microphones and
computers doing this [__] magic what
like yeah it's like
yeah yeah unbelievable unbelievable I
just remembered how I first time saw the
trees and the birds and it seems like
first time but I was then I don't know
38 years old maybe like how how I didn't
see like right and I'm in my backyard
where I have been like eight or nine
years and I'm seeing like first time my
backyard wow like the trees so beautiful
seeing the birds jumping and I'm
laughing I remember that I was sitting
in the hammock and uh and yeah watching
like that and then singing and and then
watching to my um window and seeing that
husband is
like what she's doing there she have
lost her mind maybe because she thought
he thought that yeah yeah because I was
shock like really so like like like the
veil like something was lifted and then
everything was bright and so alive yeah
and absolutely
unknowingness it's not look like oh
that's a tree I know yeah yeah that's
right right right right yeah yeah love
that like fresh and new all the time
like I blinks and wow wow like and here
it was like couple of months that kind
of um high high of life
right yeah
oh yeah that and so ordinary and so
beautiful so simple and so
beautiful this this state the statement
that um when a when a child is taught
that a bird is like a certain name like
it's a name of a bird or whatever it no
longer actually sees the rawness of the
bird it only sees like the name and that
name labeled Association and um yes the
raw the rawness kind of yeah it Con
there's like a contraction in the body
of the raw magic into like this is not
it and it can be found and I will find
it um and I will look under every Rock
and including all kinds of apparently
unethical things
um massive military industrial complexes
or all kinds of perverse things um just
to just to get what's not missing and
another thing that I was coming up to
say was that with the whole um the magic
of the apparent Veil cuz it's not even
there and yet it also apparently can
release and then also apparently the
veil or the mask or the character is
actually what is h apparently happening
and there's like a releasing of or an
unrepressed to be how it's supposed to
function here in this in this stage this
this dis play so just what a bunch of
weird [__] that doesn't make any sense
and doesn't have no
ground
yeah uh total Free
Fall nothing to hold them yeah there is
no Landing no
end as this doesn't have a start or
beginning yeah it's like uh the Seeker
wants to know uh what where it started
or where it came or this have to have a
source it's like where the beginning of
beginning there is no
beginning this is timeless
yes yeah time is illusion and this
apparent me is time traveler are moving
seeming Through Time nice nice I came
from past no my here there are my goals
my future oh there's death death I don't
like death yes yes it feels so real that
I I I was born I am living this is real
I am real my life and and this has a
meaning or it have to have a meaning and
then somewhere there is a death yeah but
there is somewhere there there is no
nowhere else there is this so this is
death this is life this is aliveness
nice
simultaneously love that yes yes exactly
yeah I completely completely Timeless I
love how I love how you called the me a
a time traveler the apparent me is a
time traveler yeah yeah yeah that's
hilarious and there is no me and there
is no time and there is no moment
yeah oh it's ironical yeah TR what a big
ass such a big Assumption of yeah of uh
of of of being of being real of being
solid and therefore the birth being real
and the death being real and that
there's something other than just this
yeah such a big assumption and then that
assumption there's all this hedging I
wanted to say that to hedging against
death so do do you know what that means
hedging it's like you you set up all
kinds of things to try to like
preventatively avoid and like death and
then set yourself up for you know like
oh my gosh I got
to through my actions I can try to like
I can try to hedge against it I can I
can be good I'll be fulfilled as long as
I get these things before I'll
apparently die you know and so then that
script is like running so strongly and
it's perfect but yeah
yeah yeah
yeah oh
boy wow and there's I mean
like I mean there's nothing more really
to say I mean what what you what you
shared there a bit ago was so good
really yeah the Alpha and Omega No
Beginning No End yeah just this I mean
there's nowhere else to go there's
nothing else to get like
yeah
yeah yeah that's that's the apparent
Liberation for no one yeah
yeah although in the story I just had
one uh email also somebody who I have
done oneon-one once and after that we
have email and he was explaining quite
well how the me is dissolving there
apparently like really uh the anxious
feelings are rising it literally fits he
wrote uh that I may die physically it's
it's it's intense and it's like losing
my life I feel like it's falling apart
or I'm falling off or and he said that I
don't know how to explain it but he
tried to a little bit Yeah it it felt
here also at the same that s similar
like somehow everything starts to fall
off stories and then you see that I'm
just um painting the picture right now
with the words uh that um yeah like
everything falling off and then it's
like what the [__] there is no ground
and understanding that it's just a free
fall you may try to hold on but it's
just attachments that makes you more
Sofer because there's nothing to hold on
yeah yes yes yeah and of course you
can't let go when Letting Go doesn't
happen because there is no one holding
on so it's innocently already full and
complete yeah but of course not for the
Seeker for the parent Seeker who is
feeling like oh I want also what you got
and saying I didn't got anything that's
the problem you want as long as there is
this who wants something it doesn't
happen or if there is Imagination how
this should be how good it should be how
Blissful it should be it is never what
you are imagining it's not it is already
this imagination happening in this is
already fullness appearing as that
yeah gosh it's so I love like the the
Free Falling and then the like the the
the trying like the the impecc leness
like I'm trying to use an easier word
cuz of the English like the flawlessness
like without flaw Perfection of that
freef falling of infinity and then this
sort of like you know like kind of like
uh but I
[Laughter]
can it was like infinite
orgas yeah
yeah yeah the P the power of of [__] it
is
so so good
yeah
yeah it happened here apparently like er
tried to understand what these guys are
talking about Jim and and Tony and then
Emerson and and it was
like [__] it I don't understand the
English so well uh every sentence is
some word that I don't understand it was
like trying little bit but then it was
[__] it yeah yeah I can't get this so I
stopped I stopped trying to get this
apparently but I didn't do it it was
surrendering by no one and this is just
a story because I'm telling it now at
that time it didn't felt like
surrendering or it was still frustrating
yeah it was still like contracted when
it hears this message it it went very
contracted actually and it hated this
message it it hated Jim and Tony and
even Emerson now he's lots of love all
these guys they are so compassionate and
and still I don't need to understand um
everything said because yeah it doesn't
matter Haven never mattered but but in a
story when there is seeking this there
is this sense that maybe that's why I
don't get it because I don't understand
or because of
the English or something yeah but then
it was [__] it yeah yeah when the and
then it was done when the body acts on
the um the like that that
frustration it can also fascinatingly
enough create more Division and
separation and anxiety and spinning for
itself um and then there's sort of the
like
releasing of that like
uh in in a in a way it is some sort of
like a
um I don't know if it really it kind of
is like a hatred in a way it is kind of
like a hatred it's like a hatred for um
for like for o for others that appear to
know more or whatever it is and then
that
uh it with that like act acting on that
can be like whoa like there can be a lot
of like quote karmic
consequences
uh but
also um like the release of that of that
uh of of anything that's being in that
freef fall Flawless freef fall the
releasing
and then the full fullness of
releasing um that was always there like
the baby always had it like era as a
baby always was the Perfection and then
there was that apparent this all this
all this weird apparent story and of
contraction and release and blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
[__] blah blah
yeah
ah yeah yeah yeah and and of course you
can um stay looping in this frustration
that oh I never get it I never get this
I can never get this I'm gonna die like
this and and it's just a Storyteller
telling the story over and over again
and even that you are not doing yeah if
there is a choice or free will stop it
stop the seeking don't you hear what
they saying that you can't get
this yeah yeah but you don't have any
any power any any any will that you do
anything that that frustration
autonomously happening apparently and
then the The Joy also autonomously of no
longer that frustration of trying to get
something when it already is yeah
MH MH oh my goodness
yeah and all emotions feelings are
ownerless although when there is the
sense of I am it owns everything this
this
me that uh yeah this is my feeling this
is my
emotion um he said something to me right
and blah blah blah blah blah blah but
these are all just what's naturally is
occurring or happening there is no one
doing anything or owning any feelings or
yeah they they are all empty and there
are no bad and good feelings these are
all uh labels in in the
Stream yeah yeah but bu bu may enjoy
more warm weather than cold weather also
natural there is no me who prefers the
weather it's just a body yeah yeah yeah
yeah apparent buddy right right let's be
correct
gosh yeah oh my gosh no no
ownership what what a what blessing
to
have apparently contracted into a my
thought or my feeling or ownership of my
my my and then see that it was always
just the feel it was always just a
thought it was always just whatever the
body's apparent preference is and what a
blessing to then kind of
be be
obviously uh one with all body with all
um yeah and just to see how obvious it
is that it's t
Timeless non-entity just whatever ever
is apparently bodying and however it's
bodying and like the freedom of
it as it is like the Perfection of it as
it
is even though it appears in all these
insane apparently insane ways
yeah yeah what the
[__] yeah and that's not what the me
wants because it doesn't deny anything
any
feelings is this there going to be
sadness even the feeling guilty is free
to arise yeah in the story here was lots
of guiltiness in every situations I I
don't have a story where it came
probably somewhere from the conditioning
and and uh right right right young age
yeah and uh guilt and you can say you
can be wrong you can be wrong it's
possible to be wrong yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah some somehow no idea or even the
wasn't um related with era there was
some situation in family era still felt
guilty because they felt sad or bad and
then ER was like also guilty but
uh uh like last year or something like
that my mom almost died and uh and D
died
apparently and uh we had argument my mom
had was still ill but wasn't in our
place anymore I was like the caretaker
for a while after the accident and um
and yeah we had an
argument and uh it was the same like we
are talking right now just the topic
wasn't I wasn't interested anymore in
this these stories right uh she's a
little bit in spirituality uh still
right and uh yeah so I was telling that
Mom stop it I'm not interested let's
change the to topic but for her it was
very painful because he she literally
felt like she's losing the torture
because in the story we had very
codependent uh relationship exactly yeah
but something here died so it was felt
from mother's side that um somehow she's
losing the daughter exactly and I was I
was seeing my my mom first time in my
life uh crying right she was so out of
what what she used to be and then I I
started to scan the body I was like
waiting when the guilty feeling is
arising because it was normal yes yes
and I'm like scanning all my body my mom
is crying and running away from our
place and I can't find the guilty
feeling anymore boom I love that yeah
yes yeah and of course there wasn't
anything wrong in the situation no one I
I didn't say anything bad also but
somehow she's meant
body was also very very uh weak at that
time still and uh and yeah but I can say
that guilty the feeling is also free to
arise it have arised here and and for
some characters that make come the story
but okay now now this feeling shouldn't
be here maybe that means that me is back
I don't know here it's like when you see
that Santa isn't real you don't I don't
know it doesn't seem to change real back
to real and uh wow there's so many
things that collapse there I love that
story with Mom because the guilt
collapses the shame collapses the people
pleasing
collapses um all of those scripts um the
validating
collapses um all of those things
collapse and it's it's an it's a diff it
it's the same freedom but in a way it's
a different texture or taste of it when
it's not being um
when that when that visceral guilt is
not you know going and okay but I gotta
I will still validate or I will still
hear out the story or I will still
people please or I will still yeah yeah
yeah yeah Mommy Daddy yeah governments
yeah you know it's like its own like
that whole thing collapses into the the
the freedom of of chaos and Anarchy and
joy and Bliss and peace of
decentralization and prosperity and just
trust that unified bodies can build a
beautiful new world um and that there's
no um that whole mommy daddy thing is
just so that's such a fascinating
component of the of the guilt and the
shame and the um lesser than also and
part of it does appear like part of like
Liberation part of release is apparently
um a destroying the scripts that are
running the destroying the ideas and
programs around around mommy daddy
government to Guru tell me truth tell me
truth tell me how to be I will listen to
you I will validate you I will feel
shame or guilt if I don't people please
or whatever all that
stuff yeah blah blah blah blah blah blah
yeah yeah yeah oh my gosh cuz it can be
so imagine I mean this just happened
also in the summer with with parents too
but like the parents in a way if if they
feel like real solid entities one of the
main things that is said is well now you
will be my continuation you will be my
grandchild
machine so there's a there's a strong
there's a strong
um like like like contracted within the
body that is then trying to in a Way
project itself onto its child to say
that because I'm a real solid entity in
time that now you as my child will you
have to be my continuation and make me
grandchildren and so then there's that
so then if you like kind of like
accepting that is like okay I will
listen uh uh and then like finally there
can be like a rejection and like a a
release of the repressed repressed
energy and be like I am not just your
grandchild machine and I this will do
whatever it does without that those
conditioned ideas and so and there's
endless scenarios like that that happen
not just with parents but with all kinds
of Dynamics in life and um and that's
all part of like non non-repressing and
non people pleasing
non-contracting yeah yeah somehow here
in in a story when this um pandemic uh
started and somehow this real
life started to change like here sorry I
put the lights on maybe yeah yeah go
ahead I love the sunset that's happening
right now it's so
pretty holy [__] that's
pretty I I love the I love I love the
contrast of that
Darkness right with all of the different
Hues of light wow yeah it's amazing what
a [__] like that was every day we are
going to the beach or yesterday we went
and watched the sun set and to Day
morning we were running to the beach and
watching the sun rise it's amazing play
of colors here yes yeah but the sun is
cool I was like walking in the
prominade is it the right word I don't
know yeah prominade yeah yeah yeah
prominade prominade yeah yeah yeah and
and I was watching how the Sun was
rising and when the sun is rising on the
sea then you see the light Corridor in
the on the sea where the sun is rising
yeah right and and and your eyes see
this but all all eyes it doesn't matter
where they are they see the same way
that the light is coming you know I'm
moving and the light is it is so cool I
have never um thought about this way
that yeah you can see it from this
reflection or this light is reflecting
back
yeah yeah Ah that's the story of uh here
uh The Awakening happened in the story
although I say that when when there is
someone who got awakened it's still a
dream yeah so the dream here went so
wild this pandemic
think it somehow wak something up here
like when I having the night uh
nightmare uh sometimes it's so so crazy
that the body itself somehow wakes it up
from The Nightmare in the middle of the
night dream and this Daydream
somehow this real life what I thought
was real felt more and more cream you
know it can't be that you you lock down
all the
and all this kind of [__] was
happening and then it was like turning
off the news um not listening to radio
when driving with car not watching the
TV no news life was perfect again right
although full on Madness was was going
on but yeah something was it was so off
that Shak shake this and then it was
like what's the purpose or meaning of
life like is it from Monday to Friday
you work from 9 till 5: until you are 70
then you are sick can't travel it can't
be only that exactly yeah yeah just to
be the
labor
right yeah but this is of course uh
waking up inside the dream dream of
reality but from that I guess the
seeking started from spirituality what's
the purpose what's the
meaning it's not just working from
Monday to Friday there have to be
something El something deeper yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that seems like
a common theme of of the story is the
contraction from the apparent Matrix and
then seeking something more and then
having a a story about Spiritual
Awakening and then just obviously seeing
that nothing ever changed that it was
always the same and that this is
obviously Unity
obviously yeah but the spirituality
sells so much hope there is so good
place to go to seek yeah yeah
yeah but uh this what shared here
doesn't sell or promise anything uh yeah
it's devastating for the me a a
spiritual
candy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
no candy or or or material candy either
yeah nothing is going to give you what
you already are
yeah
yeah but you can play that game
apparently that you lost something and
now you are trying to find what you lost
you don't you don't have a memory but
but yeah it's it's like the soul the
story of Soul living in different bodies
reincarnation all that and this lifetime
I have these learnings or teachings I
have to do this this this maybe after 10
or I don't know 100 lifetime I'm the
lighten one yeah yeah yeah but yeah I
have work to do here right right right
learning and yeah right it it keeps this
disillusion yeah
yes all it wants to do is to survive me
doesn't want to die yes yes yes he wants
to survive yes and it's a dream dream of
separation and lack and attainment and
uh all that and and then it that that
can apparently just spin around in a
circle for endlessly cuz that's the
fascinating thing is that um you're
talking about this a bit yesterday is
that if there's like spinning around in
a circle but then you get a material
attainment like you got that fancy thing
that you were looking for you at least
can you can sort of tell that oh that's
that like look the dissatisfaction was G
was the satisfaction was gone back to
dissatisfaction so quickly but with but
with like spirituality is so like
ethereal and conceptual and ideas and
stuff that there's almost endless things
that you can bounce around to and then
oh and never feel satisfied in those
endless things there's no nothing like
kind of
viscerally obviously hits you that that
that that material thing didn't satisfy
well with those Concepts nothing ever
sort of hits you like that but
apparently it does exhaust at some at
some point and um thank goodness that it
can exhaust cuz can you imagine like a
an apparent 50 more years or something
of feeling unworthy and unho and just
seeking like a
narcissist yeah no very very difficult
to imagine even uh for tomorrow here
yeah yeah imagine imagine that waking up
tomorrow and being like Oh I'm unho I
got to go find truth yeah imagine how
[__] suffering that would be yeah
yeah I I I I still can feel the the the
feeling yeah and also when I'm talking
uh one on once with apparent Seekers
because when I'm hearing the story it
feels like this one have been there also
apparently there is some memory arising
and then there is compassion arising
towards to that but but yeah sorry I
can't give anything I can't promise you
that you die because all I can say that
there is already already no one yeah
there's already die yeah yeah I just
reflect that this is already yeah yeah
Perfection or or fullness appearing as
that or unconditional love or Oneness I
don't care whoever however call this
this is nameless so yeah yeah I I don't
care I I hear only the empty words yeah
I I feel I feel like I reflect that and
then I also reflect um if there's like a
very strong
uh like energy that really wants to sort
of do something in order to uh release
more apparently that uh sometimes it can
actually just be obvious to say like
yeah just go and do that thing like go
and do that thing that you feel like is
going to is going to you know there's
nothing
you um because that's also apparently
what
happened is that what whatever happened
in that thing
you
know it didn't cause it but it it it has
to be exhausted in a way it just has to
work itself out it and it and it does it
automatically it just it does it like a
bird flies around and like pecks at like
worms or whatever and like gets its or
you know the like there's alpacas
outside right now and they're like you
know grabbing the grass and it's just
like the the the alpaka animals just you
know it's just that's the function it's
just the function of it and it's the
same thing with this looping thing it's
just a function and it just does itself
out
yeah so if it feels like it's got to
[__] go to India or whatever then it
just [__] has to and it just goes
into you know and like it's going to be
hilarious when it when it
[__] when it sits in the the empty
Throne that always was the wholeness
that always was
yeah yeah and then you're just laughing
about this that that IDE idea that oh I
had to go to India and I don't know wash
the toilets or meditate 10 hours a day
or whatever you can only laugh then you
can only laugh a cosmic joke yeah
[Laughter]
yeah and then you can say it here on
this like on this podcast conversation
and then perhaps it'll be heard like
okay why are they laughing about like
going to India and like all this kind of
stuff and like you know not being able
to find what's not
lost yeah yeah you you may say it
thousand times but you hear it only once
or you may listen it thousand times but
you hear it only once nice that's
another fun way to say it yeah yeah yeah
so that's what it was in a way yeah
right go ahead I didn't understand what
they are laughing about like Emerson
there said this is it and everyone
laughing and he also and I was like yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I guess yeah I I forgot myself
to talk and then forgotting that there
are apparent others so I forgot how to
be more gentle maybe sometimes to
direct yeah yeah yeah what are laughing
about it's serious thing I'm going to
India yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
what are you what are you making fun of
me it's so
serious no I'm not laughing at anyone
I'm just laughing with you my my my
seeking journey is so important okay how
can you be so
offensive yeah my me yeah is most
important and most important and special
yes yes nice yeah yeah you hurt my
feelings yeah yeah but you don't have
feelings there is no one's it's so funny
how it claims yeah yeah my claim claim
claim claim yeah
yeah wow what a fun conversation holy
cow thanks for inviting and uh happy to
found you somehow you appeared in
YouTube or someone suggested to watch
the you you and Emerson and I'm very
lazy Watcher uh I barely watch something
but then I watched two your two videos
and it was so fun and you do so small
Clips also I love it yeah little I don't
have consistency to watch long videos
and I also sometimes do long videos but
I'm not doing it it just happens
yeah yeah yeah yeah same I I I think I
saw your content um even a while ago I
started to see it but then uh most
recently I I saw uh you interview
Emerson Emerson interview you also and
yeah and and it is exciting yeah this
was a fun podcast it was very
um it was It was kind of it was Wild and
Free in a beautiful way I I yeah I loved
I loved where we went and how we played
and yeah it was it was
cool yeah and very random and actually I
forgot I forgot that I don't know you
that's when you're talking first time I
just remember this is our first like
video call yeah yeah that's right yeah
that's cool too yeah exactly yeah yeah
our first video call was a podcast yeah
yeah first date first date and it's like
some sort of like um there's a yeah
there's like a Resonance of of play and
joy and like alignment or whatnot and it
feels really fun
yeah cool cool yeah so more to play um
on I wanna I want to show one more time
let me show
the this one yeah
so this is A's website again nonduality
doe where's that what's the E by the way
Estonia oh Estonia oh it's the Estonia
end of a website got
it I love it how there's so um few in
Estonia that you can get the non
duality. that's great and then here's
her YouTube channel too so go and check
it out the links are in the bio
um and there's also
what what is it is it uh like Zoom
meetings and stuff that that you can
sign up for where you'll get absolutely
nothing from
them
y just have
fun exactly just have fun just literally
have fun yes
yeah okay well let me I'll end the
stream and then you and I will stay for
just another moment thank you everyone
for tuning in much
love much
[Music]
love adios
adios oh wow cool animation yeah let's
get that I don't have I don't
have ciao
[Music]
ciao